it's cop rock Monday and I'm COFF Monday
and welcome back me off Monday its [ __ ]
Rock Monday so means we rock with our
cocktail yeah all right now you got to
calm down and how was your how was your
weekend Brendon how was your week I saw
you on Saturday sorry
that's right companion saw me and said
my companion I know that you go we we
wrap and bring us epic fellas epic of it
I saw you know what I just went hey
don't say that but hey but don't say up
it yeah
don't do that epic fight pain was fun as
always you brought great cheese I
brought great cheese yeah too much she
didn't feel so good feel good either it
feels so good I feel good either
and then I that morning at my son's bday
party freakin ine post pictures of the
cake and stuff it's always weird pose I
took that cheese recycled it by the way
without even wrapping it putting it put
it in back in the box back in the
[ __ ] heart
yeah the paper brown paper Biograph from
Whole Foods took that wine and walked
right in the Frank Rose house and watch
the Tyson Fury fight with that with the
same cheese took that cheese out all
shitty and just threw it on a play they
even know no people dug right in tight
in did you bring the wine taster did
sure did read the wine yep
open that up to my Papa fancies himself
a chef an Italian chef and try to speak
Italian stuff and so he went he's been
to Italy twice no he knows pastas about
all the pasta just find he's into food
yeah and so when I was a kid he's make
the best [ __ ] spaghetti but it's just
your normal like red sauce with sausage
in it but now you know he'd tell me all
the stuff we don't care anyways but I am
pretend I do right so he just friends
all day making it with the meatballs of
course and then he's tell me about all
the meatballs he's doing by hand and
didn't watch chance whatever so he's
making all the he's making all the
meatballs I'm like well that's not good
dad and so it comes but now he dumps I
don't know half a bottle of wine red
wine into the sauce because that's what
he saw to him anyway so then he gives it
to me I go down this tastes like
straight red wine and he goes that's cuz
that's cuz you know what you're trying I
go well no it's spaghetti sauce so yeah
but it tastes like red wine though you
know cuz I saw you dump that look at the
bottle there's like barely
I saw you pour that in there and he goes
well yep that's cuz you don't know food
it's gonna burn off as the day goes on
ah that's fine I'm sure that's right now
what I just tried it's red wine with
sausage it's it's and I feel sick tomato
sick yeah
because basically just took red wine and
dumped sausage in it not a sausage and I
feel sick and have this huge fight that
I can't wait to watch but I feel sick to
my stomach
and here's what's gonna burn off if you
ask go by its supposed to reduced yep
I'll close can I want to stop see Divis
it up Divis it up right Mike's
tortellinis populist or least cheat meal
gives you up can't wait for the fight
take up ideas what do you think now yo
you know I say it it tastes like red
wine dad you guys you all right whatever
and then everyone else I won't die cake
tell him it tastes like red wine well
they didn't do it as an Italian whose
grandmother made incredible sauce whose
a hundred percent of time I'm at a
Harmsen
let's go up something and watch them
make sauce it was passed down generation
I have never and friends with four beats
young guys who own restaurants yep that
is nuts ever heard of anybody putting
red wine into sauce you don't do the
Debbie tell you the time but as you hate
me for this they retain water
he made French onion soup and apparently
there's you put brandy and like the
thing and I was I don't know 14 we put
too much brandy in there so I take that
I go oh my god but I didn't want to
offend us I kept bean it's a little
brownie up forty on hammer yeah that's
what happened you might I guess I looked
at me he's little tipsy goes I think I
put too much alcohol and so I don't know
what his thing is that's really supposed
to put alcohol like never heard of it no
I haven't there's no arguing though
there's no argue no arguing no yeah he's
got well he's an alpha
your dad's an alpha male and he's not I
see where you get your you guys are both
competitive the whole family the whole
family's compare exhausting chase
competitive two of them but Jays the
worst one of it yeah he's not giving an
inch but Jase so right most of the time
it's exhausting yeah you can't you know
your excites some stuff yes relax like
you know sports but he'll sport yours
deep with you in cars in sports yeah he
knows more about sports and cars and
yachts football but yeah even football
he'll maybe he'll argue the fighting you
can't no I had finds different finds
different
now when I was you it what I would I do
what I wish because I was watching the
fight at Frank's with a lot of people a
lot of actors directors producers here
yep I would have
when I saw our text thread and Rogen
said Tyson figured out in the 12th round
last fight that that Wilder can't fight
moving backwards I would have this is
the person I am I would have taken that
not and I would have said regurgitation
I would have said you know Tyson
I'll tell you what Tyson knows he knows
that fury can't fight backwards now
watch how he's doing this you see what
he's doing and I would take that as my
own knowledge sure but it would make me
look good in front of strangers yeah why
why am i doing you seem knowledgeable
you want you wanna be cool you want to
bring something to the table makes me a
little tougher makes me look tougher I
got I understand the game of fight sure
right so did you not do that I didn't
get the text oh yeah a [ __ ] party it
bothered me I didn't know what was going
on I lost some money well what I thought
was going on was he burst his eardrum
and broke his hand cuz he kept touching
his right hand well you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
why look he was bleeding out of zero and
i thought is equilibrium was off because
he got hit in the back of the head and
and he looked there wobbling more and
more hey don't condescend to me more
don't con his enemy more allows you at
the house you were at no but what would
you didn't think that he got his
equilibrium got off and he was bleeding
out of his ear so it could have been a
burst eardrum why left I get his ass
whooped from the opening bell I thought
he wasn't present they didn't show up
and Tyson Fury outclassed and beat the
[ __ ] out of them and I will see the
rematch crew but I felt like before that
it by in the air even before you burst
eardrum UV clear you're gonna be a
little wobbly yeah so is that did that
happen no it did it no he didn't have a
broken jaw or his eardrum was in person
this is just bleed knives there and so
you know I why cuz that's what yeah yeah
that's what got more and it could be all
wrong more don't call me my alright say
because cuz I'm gonna tell you something
hmm
I'm coming in with Crocs but also do I
tell you
pop you in the mouth hey I'm gonna piss
you in your you'll try I'm gonna piss in
your dress try and I'll slap you in the
mouth or rip your crotch on the pissed I
don't want to do this this is Monday but
I stretched and I'm slap your mouth you
understand we don't let's not turn it
into a slap fest cuz it's gonna be a
sweet oh I love writing more now you've
been around your actor friends yeah and
I know you guys are yeah and which one
which it's just like a parrot one one
goes his eardrums off your jump up off
off and condescending grtt art Oh
tanning trt tanning tea white boy morons
volume warns that's the worst thing to
cause some problem is they're even worse
[ __ ] I told you so great it's awesome
great my father this is a favorite word
my father will see a dude on TV um this
guy this guy is a more it's best
disabled like that now you're [ __ ] well
that guy's a [ __ ] I'll say something
how about well he said this my dad goes
well he's a [ __ ] when you're ready
hey how about O'Connor I like politics
with my dad and he's balls deep in it
and I said there's a very standard and
even he was like know that well [ __ ]
with because with politics saying what
you do with fighting I just I watch
stuff on YouTube and on CNN or Fox News
and then I hear them say something then
I'm like that makes sense I said some
about Bernie it's hard to laugh in the
rich yeah cuz you don't have a lot of
time so you'll hear somebody saying you
know they must have done their
fact-checking well then you have a show
or whatever so I figured they got the
info from somewhere so I was like off my
dad's were driving out of Malibu we're
talking politics he's gone I know you
know I like Bernie other thing is you
know the tax and the rich stuff like
that and he goes what and I was like I
knew I was in trouble alright when i
chat with
louisia me taxing the rich cheese but
you're not you know that because through
it by numbers
I think about that year and he goes
through the years you think it [ __ ]
would say that guy I'm like well I'm not
I'm not [ __ ] that I didn't say that I
was like want to be clear chest to be
clear Fox News you're putting a hand on
your chest maybe you might be a [ __ ]
but not it's not me I'm just saying yeah
because the problem is we don't have
time to get deep into all subjects I
don't have time
my dad embarrassed me one time Sarah
Palin was asked a question and then I
heard people go how could she not that
know that question I knew better and I
went what a [ __ ] she didn't know this
and my father looked at mangoes do you
know I stopped you stay in it no I just
opted out ago I stopped and I went I
went if I was in her position I would
yeah there you go
and he goes thank you he moved out I was
so [ __ ] humiliating Stila but I
deserved it I deserved it so funny it
was so funny I was like oh this stuff
yeah he goes are you done shouting your
opinion because I if you want me to
interject some thought into this I could
do you know it's all oh [ __ ] I was like
sorry man but all of us have I love my
deaf but didn't help can you well your
dad's kind of pretty low-key he don't
say much you got sticks his business
until I tell you but until you start
spouting stuff something about someone
like Bernice - yeah how great he would
be for the economy uh now you're gonna
have my dad call me a [ __ ] again as I
say at the Trump Hotel Vancouver why and
then coming [ __ ] you don't that's why I
think I called you a [ __ ] because he
used called me more I'm all wrong pass
down trauma kit why they used to put
more on it forever right
Maura but you might not call me a [ __ ]
stare the tumblr why would you do that
either he's some sort of [ __ ] hey man
that's call me [ __ ] one more time
coming more time and then give me your
wine [ __ ] spaghetti sauce I'm not to
freak out and then you know I'm super in
American out right now
I was like ah it's gonna be such a great
weekend I got Tigers birthday I hit the
Wilder fight the fight companion
and then American Idol Sunday night the
Tom look for two so my cheat me Alma by
my pistachio ice cream from Jenny's
which is the best ice cream on so I get
the best ice cream they have pistachio
pistachio ice cream I've had it I love
to show everything Jenny's channel has
ice cream before processional so Jenny's
I have you got it from Jenny's what does
Jenny's that we do oh it's the best of
us oh so the bet all they deliver to
Papa
free shipping at close range drops it
off same guy what's up shop what's up
dawg boom I get three three little pints
of it right and I will eat that whole
pint now there's a cheat day I'll eat
the whole pie girls good you're
emotional like the whole pie now really
whole pie but are you a nice cup of
coffee this is nine o'clock at night you
think coffees [ __ ] with me more her
adrenal glands are so [ __ ] nothing
gets me excited anymore that's quick
Jeni's ice cream the pistachio it's the
best it's will knock your dick how much
in there it's the best Oh fantastic Wow
how could I know she can do what I like
to do is get the double folded vanilla
this is a cheat code for you [ __ ] I
use the double folded vanilla then they
have us our caramel that they sell it
comes in a little bottle not much you
know what the expenses are stronger is
my favorite it's a nice that that's
let's not do the podcast good I'm salt
installs nice dude was I saying what
there I'll take you to Jenny's right now
I'm doing the salt smell so nice - it's
very nice more like Jenny's more but
anyway so you get you get the you get
their caramel you can go to it chin if
you go to the caramel so I get that I
get the double fold of vanilla with a
jar of the caramel it's some mom-and-pop
shop caramel sauce dude and then what
you do is you dip your spoon and the
caramel dip that in the vanilla and eat
it it's not right so it's live in dude
that's living so anyways so that's
alright I get my ice cream I get the
[ __ ] caramel I'm all excited I'm in
my [ __ ] sweats my cozies as duiker
calls them I'm in my cozies right my
cozies I get my [ __ ] ugh flippers on
I'm rain American I'll here we go it's
American Idol we'll pop a shopton stop
talking
he critiques every singer I miss the
entire thing I can focus on javis taking
the singers yeah yeah we had a fourth
judge in that [ __ ] a fourth I
didn't know you know Jay Shah was here
too nope okay
Jaden come to Vancouver either it sounds
that Jeff fell on right how was that
fantastic
it's great right it's great Lovejoy FL j
Vancouver's got some cool [ __ ] going on
although I mean rainy and cold Oh No
hi sunny met up with my boy Jesse cats
took me to his sushi spot he's a local
born in that sushi
hey the best sushi have ever had is it
man oh yeah Vancouver's great sushi do
you remember that student we went to
women but it must be 12 to one guys do
girls yeah
dying died me dimes great shopping
that's right yeah Vancouver's dope I had
a friend who was in Vancouver and got
hit up by this girl and they were having
a great love affair talk and then he's
like let's hang out she comes she hangs
with him and then they go back to the
hotel and she goes not so fast
it's $1,000 and she's she has every
right to do that yeah and I would give
her 15 we been I thought we were how do
you read the room - oh no I look like
[ __ ] - yeah yeah and he was like but she
was like oh did you think oh no I love
you but I need a thousand dollars and
you've earned it daddy and you Virna and
daddy's gonna give it to you and I said
to him did you go to the ATM and he said
did you write a check he paused and I
went that's a yes and that's okay that's
a yes that's okay and even though your
feelings were hurt you went got a great
time your life Canadian dollars better
in Iran damn right damn dude so Papa
here went across the street from the
Trump Hotel cuz there's a steakhouse I
forget what it's called two famous
Steakhouse there went in there at the
bar by myself
then Vancouver Canucks house just float
around there and boy were they on your
boy cuz I like this hockey helmet I get
the hockey here well you got some time
here and you got and you got some you
got some the I call hungry eyes I was at
the keg I call you hungry eyes are out
on your boy cuz I look like your
defenseman for the [ __ ] football
right for the cannot big boy with five
and Papa got a nice steak a little
whiskey whiskey little side of shrimp
that's a man vegetables [ __ ] man me Oh
what kind of kind of whiskey to get
Wyatt low trace did you have the bottle
on the I think you shared the bottle on
the table or something sexy about you
it's just it's just virtual Cygnet these
hoes come and get this real uh-huh dude
really God you had the whiskey in the
steak yeah and then and then you know
you got the hockey helmet in Canada big
golf sleeves dude comes at Moth Batman I
was nice Jack and of course it's Kenneth
oh sweet jacket on so I'm batting him
off
Farrakhan Jackie no big deal I'm Batna
mom got some money we're in ten thousand
dollars whatever that don't change
Patamon ten thousand dollars in about
here's a penny more old guys old morons
right they're morons rich dudes yeah
this girl
smoke show tits [ __ ] sleeved up half
asian half black tie my dick so hard so
she it's a she she sits next these guys
yeah and he's like baby what do you want
to drink the cock-block [ __ ] the top
block [ __ ] bartender Rudy calling
[ __ ] rockaroonie concoct bunk [ __ ] yeah
comes over and goes I guess the time you
know each other is what do you will call
her Amy goes what are you doing here Amy
and she's like grabbing Intel she's like
she and she's a smoke show dripping
[ __ ] sex and she goes oh just grandma
drink my hair friend and he looks at
then goes huh and then it's more you
know [ __ ] read the Ruby [ __ ] it
goes oh my god you'd only reason she's
got a drink you guys are paying for it
right
she was so embarrassed that I would be
like hey dude come here
hey you [ __ ] blocker shut up yeah that's
what he said yeah he's like oh my god
you know she's only sit down you guys
she's you paying for this right and
she's like you're an ass was he joking
uh I think he was like kind of drunk but
also like trying to kill these guys ah
I was like how you today made me feel so
that's like guys who are you know those
guys go right across on earth
that's the guy there are guys out there
so all of a sudden you're dating a girl
the guy goes you know he's got a girl in
every port right or whatever don't get
used all the times go every pore right
at least 7,000 leaves you'll see any lag
but scallywag
no kid under 40 says port anymore I mean
these are all there got gay k-dubb but
there are dudes who want a [ __ ] box for
no reason and sell another dude down the
river about a one-day bro will mention
names is with a smoke show no bad guys
yes throughout a party he goes to the
bathroom another dude swipes INGOs but
you know he has herpes right Oh God so
he goes back bathroom and she's acting
all weird he's explained with you and
then finally in the car she goes your
friend told me I would kill he was like
what the [ __ ] I would kill that guy
I mean no that's like you know cuz then
you'd have to be like look I got stung
by bees relax all over my dick house and
then he would like to hand Soph to give
my [ __ ] in sting once a month that's a
holiday they go away yeah I feed the
bees I feed the bees I feed the either
away just a hater what a [ __ ] you
know that is no so our other friend
we're close with the other friend
another friend we kind of voted off the
island huh you know the friend he's got
a friend for support dude thank
port-to-port Geoff fun watching the
fight fight I did else so bad for a
Wilder I did to us broken I loved him
and I did too but I felt bad because I
think that Tyson Fury is a problem
Wilder will never solve never and I
don't know Amos and I also think that
Anthony I think Wilder in that moment
became number three in the
I think Joshua does the same thing to
him I don't know Russia does it that
style I mean definitely a closer fight
now that his Ostrom but Joshua was a
better matchup for him but yeah he did
that he did the problem the problem is
and you know experts have said this all
the time going up to it go at the end of
the day you know Wilders not the best
boxer see he has that he has the gift of
God but when it comes down to X's and
O's and fundamentals he doesn't have it
so fury scan was like cool put you on
your back foot we're even better than
you inside I'll say goes well it goes
back to what you were saying about
quarterbacks in the NFL if you if man
really well in college and you're a
runner the defense because they're
professionally good out they could get
away we're just gonna make you pass in
the pocket and read the deep we're
making you work on your weakness and
what that's what he did and so he could
probably experience that's experience
and that's being a great boxer who went
oh I know I know what he's bad at
fighting off his back foot right I mean
get him moving backwards it's crazy man
I felt so bad for him I didn't care
about the money none of that I felt I
felt so bad for me too
I was like oh you don't because I was
like oh he's a shell like he doesn't
want to be in there I'm like oh no this
is it he kept doing the weirdest thing
he kept he would stand her and kept
adjusting he kept touching this part his
right hand and I was like I've never
seen him do that that's why I thought
did he hurt his hand but it was like
I've he just wasn't he just wasn't there
I think he just realized I felt money I
wanted to stop it so bad right remember
when he was sitting down on the bench
and he was just he looked depressed he
didn't want to be in there man he just
didn't want to do it he'd let happen so
unfortunate happened for him on a big
night against the having sometimes it's
just it doesn't happen to the greats
yeah and if it does you won't know with
him we knew and I was like ah I'm
telling you I looked up when when he
took off that mask I looked at my family
ah [ __ ] really right away I went oh yeah
that's my grass my dog last [ __ ] the oil
that doesn't look like the [ __ ] water
we're used to seeing I went oh man he
looks scared he doing half or they go I
wipe at $4,500 on wait wait why why he's
like you might be content he might he's
good man financially I mean I think he's
good was he if was he afraid of the
weight difference no cuz he put on
weight which was a bath
my brother I like I have some inside
sources and they told me all these
things that made me decide to take
Wilder and I wish I didn't listen to him
because obviously costs me money but
then while and fears my favorite fighter
I've always said that he's my favorite
fighters I hated been against them but
when you look at the things leading up
to it you know while our fear is doing
exactly what needed to do to just
dominate the fight and Wilder was the
one we should have been worried about
put on the weight my brother goes I'm
telling you man don't bet on it while
we're putting on all that muscle is not
good it's a bad sign yeah I was like you
shut your fat mouth dude but but um how
about his trainer because I think it was
his a tire that he warrant to the ring
tired amount and also he also goes I
would have stopped the fight the other
coach doing that that was very smart to
stop oh you should shopping too before
three here's my prompt too when they go
to the stool and he goes back him up
right hand like that's the coaching at
this yeah I wouldn't here cuz I was
watching battle up right hand back on
that your coach Jack him up what about
the him didn't annihilate it what what
about Dyson imposing his will but it
will have to [ __ ] right that's your
could didn't have they weren't saying
anything to him it looked like I
couldn't they just back him up throw the
right hand back him up throw the right
hand but also there's listen [ __ ] you
know well we see a rematch it's in their
claws it's a I thought Eddie her and was
talking this morning on the BTB sit out
and let these two fight Joshua [ __ ] you
[ __ ] hey you better find more on up hey
of course not sir so this thing called
contract
yeah but why they have to remit they
have to before he fights anybody can't
yeah come on papa yeah so they have to
unless Wow so it's up to Wilder not
means up to with so if Wilder does Nam
good I'm gonna move on because I can't
win that fight he's chance him ever find
him again are not good cuz fury go cool
thanks bro and then he's gonna go fight
Joshua probably two or three times and
make a fortune biggest fight in Vegas
you know the best thing
well yeah you should fight in Vegas
though cuz it's so how dare you know
nobody has fighting right no family stay
against the holds [ __ ] twelve thousand
yeah Joshua can fight a [ __ ] the UPS
men sell 80 thousand ticket team out
with him and Fury's gonna the biggest
fight in boxing biggest by far and when
I saw Tyson I mean I'm on that stand
with the king's throne I thought to
myself boxing is so back they've made
the octet he's made the heavyweight
division so exciting and I think what
you're gonna see now is more yelling at
him weights will show up it's gonna get
a I think I want the big to be fair it's
the three of them mate but have any way
back yes
Joshua Wilder and Tyson made made it
cool yeah
the three of them not just Wow last two
fights were [ __ ] awful no one
couldn't Wilder sit out even though he's
in contract couldn't he say I'm injured
I want to sit this out whatever it is
now he's got a day after this contract
yes yes I think thirty days to go I want
three match and Eddie Hearn was talking
to us he goes well we have to fight pool
of by contract we have to do that that's
the mandatory so we're gonna do that in
like like next two months he goes and if
it's up to us we'll fight fearing the
summer we're ready to do that right now
make the deal and why and so but the
interview on BBC goes if you're the
promoter wilder what are you doing is
different story cuz if I'm working with
Wilder I say take the rematch because
that's where the most money if you don't
take the rematch you're never gonna get
it and you need the money you gotta do
it so yeah of course he's gonna do it
well you make fifty million dollars
thirty million I don't know but it just
is just such a bummer because I don't
want to see it the EON it annihilated
the first fight it's a good thing yeah
of course but when when when Wilder said
I was dealing with some stuff coming in
do we know anything insider
no injuries maybe some you know I I'm I
don't know doesn't matter doesn't matter
does it
you don't think Fury's deal and stuff
everybody's dealing with [ __ ] it doesn't
matter unless it was like you're serious
I do I broke both my hands or I broke my
jaw I got knocked out the night before
but it's if it was that serious here to
come out by now see how you haven't
heard anything nothing it's not that
serious because because I'm telling you
his team would have went on damage
control and somebody came out that night
night
we want let everybody know he blew his
dick off lighting fireworks Thursday
night was a fight clone was like oh damn
that makes sense give us the trill he
just his house is real quiet
his head wasn't he didn't want to do do
you didn't want to be there man
it was awful to see if he comes in too
far by the way he was in the first fight
it matters it matters I don't wanna see
it you can't solve the problem sure it's
too good too hard to hit man too [ __ ]
hard to hit
yeah he looked amazing I was sure eat
well I loved watch him I prefer watching
fights at home but I've been fighting to
a fight to paying for that would you
make a prediction on that wild early
Walter I'm sorry not what you need fury
Joshua yeah I think fury beat them
he's a slight favorite too yeah yeah
nothin but yeah no one's beating fears
the best everybody on the planet bars so
awkward so weird those big arms are just
so good he's so [ __ ] good 31 how old
is he yeah 31 so damn good it's crazy
he's got so much that's so young how
about retires to he woulda lost this
when he played saved by a retired guy
how about his dad called it to a tee
exacto was gonna happen he's like in a
shouting match yeah on TV his brothers
at Giant he's got two brothers that are
jealous huh
no no giant six six no I've been asking
your bet so once I hold on once it's
constant cousin yeah and he's
professional boxer that's right more so
when discuss isn't more so once his
cousins watch it yeah who's a beast put
your hand down but yeah now his cousin's
a great fighter is he yeah really good
the brothers are both big kids of just
giant kids no no mm-hmm
no big fat 64 no no no that's his cousin
that's supposed to be his brother Tom
maybe not I don't know that's a C shame
down there that's his brother right
there let me see how tall he is
shortened from 6 foot so these are
probably
Labre within camp of them you know you
read calendar hey you know the actors
too much
I say I've been around them I've
actually been around 20 years old half
brother
oh that's his brother right there this
guy's is half brother Tommy fury Jane's
probably real brother other than the
whole family then he has one more and
then his dad was a bare-knuckle fighter
Christ where'd he get his height his dad
stats huge dad's enormous yeah but his
actual brother they like manage him that
that's him there Shane great guy but
he's like you know six foot that day huh
here's one more yeah what about the guy
with the long hair there that that one
the one with the long hair down there is
that same guy yeah let's say okay his
cousin is 6xe he was sparring with I
think his cousin
yes kai forgets the cousin's name oh
that's him there the Huey
that's right Huey is this picture yeah
and Huey had a big fight almost [ __ ] you
DB almost beat the guy but got screwed
over decision yeah Hugh Fury's a beast
well that can't you help avec in that's
right
a lot of people he won that stud yeah a
lot of people thought he won that is you
sick it's too small for these guys he
know who sticks a little beast but yeah
he's a little small we talking about
fury 20 I think this time all that then
against height - yeah politics - like
you're like Wilders Paul man and give me
too much too much too much he's a beast
thumb and you never know 6 315 yeah he's
really good he's amazing
does he come out alone and janko's camp
I don't think so 33 though
[Music]
stacked but the reader yeah let's see
it's gonna be interesting I really want
to see this I'm very excited about
boxing again yeah you're getting that
Wilder fury trilogy though so don't get
too excited just the way the boxing
world works that's where they're gonna
make their money it's a bummer because
you really want see Joshua Fury badly
you could see it at then the year you
can see me buy that at least I was
seeing it I don't know maybe hopefully
her and says they want it yeah dude I
thought that Paul felt if I was [ __ ]
right with hooker yeah yeah what'd you
this weekend get me away from this this
weekend I spent time with my family my
parents came down to visit and we're
Kyle yep from NorCal and then my uncle
and his girlfriend stayed with me for
the weekend too uncle and his girl how
old your uncle uh 32 33 like that young
gentleman young gentleman you guys do
anything fun not really I was just kind
of babysitting my uncle I keep on
getting text messages from his
girlfriend he's like drunk raiding my
kitchen I said what's he do huh what's
he do uh he owns a polka shop over in
Newark and NorCal yeah I like pokey
pokies so good if it's done right it if
it's done right yeah I'm not a fan of
like the newer like pokeball places I
like it when it's pre-marinated that's
sweet I don't think screwed up the
street
sweet Finn I think feel sweet my buddy
Seth owns that place
sweet Finn yep oh oh yeah that's really
good we've had that much my I love sweet
love sweet v twice about what my kid was
playing with this little uh his dogs
friends came from school did this jump
place his team Titan Teen Titans theme
right and he's playing with it I don't
know his friends right my girl knows
long because it you know I don't know
all them I know a few that he was talked
about and there's a little cute
Australian girl jumping on him and then
we were playing dodgeball and I fall
down she grabs on me and she's like an
accent I'm like and I see I hear someone
I hear her mom with the same accent from
Australia the dad like it's shaped
really
looks like [ __ ] like a supermodel and
we start talking about what do you do as
I you know I've run a few jams I came
out from Australia I'm like oh that's
cool and a skinny gyms I know of he's
like uh
f45 I've heard of those office
that's your that you use mm-hmm and you
own a business you look like that and
you're just a dime piece Jesus Christ
let's take a look at this guy I don't
know if the beyond there man he's full
of training that for me that's 45 yeah
him and his best friend started it
Wow my phone was just talking about that
said it was great Rob fastest-growing
fitness franchise yeah they say it's not
like CrossFit it's like it's like uh
yeah circuit circuit training instant
circuit training I feel like I did one a
while ago I've done Orangetheory which I
like I could [ __ ] use some of that
man I just worked out in the [ __ ]
Pelican to actually started doing that
yeah Rob it's him Rob doesn't work out
sit on it good ones I thought you can
get some of those elsewhere really I saw
I don't I just wanna get ready to go to
the gym I just going downstairs and do
my yeah well you could do you could do
the on it program but that's cool too
because they have all the and dab all
that equipment yeah plus it's good cuz
you can kind of compete against other
people and [ __ ] that's what you do I
don't know yeah I don't know yeah bnw
can't help but it compete a little bit
oh you always do
yeah you don't and you meet people yeah
it's it's so healthy it is you're
pushing sleds I'm gonna do I love it I
gotta start there's one right up the
street here and there's one yeah I know
forty five everyone
it's also an in Venice let's think about
my my my you know my kids friends that
when I was a kid it wasn't like this
like the gift that he got cuz the you
know the private school he goes to like
what do you mean can't compete with this
the gift I mean it did the the the
amount of the cool [ __ ] that he got I'm
like did you have no idea how good you
have it oh can I skip my friend
captain's give me gifts we didn't ask
for guess anyone can afford guess they
were just come to your party and then
your parents are pay for all and they'd
have a grand old time but I mean the
shoes in the video games and I'm like
God why why even get him a gift because
he's like yeah it's all this [ __ ] right
it's crazy yeah
Mark Wahlberg yeah I think Mark
Wahlberg's uh big
Wester now - and boy stays bodied up
he's always in those that 45s guess
who's gonna have 45 this guy get on that
[ __ ] you know that Brandon yeah yeah
Mark Wahlberg's great body
doesn't he have like a crazy schedule
where he wakes up at like 3:00 or 4:00
in the morning he works out twice a day
yeah cuz he works out before his kids
get up I'm already annoyed with him lets
him at f45 up there that already annoys
me I'm gonna remember Leo sleeping a
shout out but he says he goes to bed if
he's not working out like 7 p.m. or
something cool yeah enjoy that I don't
care I got a better one
sound comic do that shit's working for
him though and Mario Lopez's body DUP
he's always been buddy let's ACC's it
always yeah Oh Mark Wahlberg oh it's
consi bodied up
yeah it's both shorter smaller smaller
dudes but still it's impressive Mark
Wahlberg's a sneaker head to man he has
his own Jordans for God's sakes they did
his own Jordan's right yeah looks good
yeah he does look good do you ever see
him in uh pain and gain with the rock I
didn't see her wear posters extraneous
yeah they're huge
well they literally they were just like
oh well these guys aren't steroids so
you guys hide it
have you seen the pictures of him in the
rock walk he's as big as the rock itself
they got a name a steroid go they took
that let's see some imagery go that one
excuse me excuse me sir that's [ __ ]
out there how fun would that be though
wouldn't it be fun if they were like
Kate Brennan you and briar and play Hans
in front you guys you can play Hans and
Franz get on steroids were they playing
where they playing bodybuilders in this
movie they were there yeah they were
like they were gym owners and the gym
wasn't doing good it's a true story
their gym owners in in Miami and the
gyms not going well so they they try to
frame this really rich guy and they take
him they kidnap him but they don't want
to let their identities out but
eventually they do they actually end up
trying to kill the guy they thought they
killed him by running him over but he
survives and then comes after them and
they're all [ __ ] y'all went to prison
just Rory [ __ ] yeah great great
Namah move is in a great movie great
really
you would love it I didn't know that I
was like I apply some though I loved it
great Fox came when did it make money oh
I'm sure I like absolutely loved it I
also love venom too so take it for what
sort yeah yeah jacked who would that be
though just to put aa shitload of muscle
I don't think if I could do all this
Terezin world I don't think with my
friend I could I could you could I don't
you could different kind of body good
dude we could get you there yeah lot of
[ __ ] what happens to my liver right
listen I don't know what happens there
but got a lot a lot what was like I was
listen to the armchair expert with Dax
Shepard and Ashton Kutcher on the drive
here and they were saying how what you
sound could be Conor McGregor in jujitsu
they're talking about how much Ashton
Kutcher he has like the yet that crazy
gene where he get some eyes stuck on
something all he cares about and they're
on set of their show figure what's
showing ash the ranch on Netflix do you
like that show I haven't watched it I
heard of them anyways so on the ranch
they're all sitting around there the
time out who could lose the most weight
you know that's good she's not big dude
as it is far as like body mass he's just
he's a thin guy and so they had this bet
and like forty people with the staff and
the set everyone we got involved and
Ashley Kutcher came in second but they
said he was just like my set
yeah maniac about it see what fast for
like 24 hours every other day they said
by the end of it he was like basically
near his deathbed but he lost like a
hundred some pounds some [ __ ] Theo
skinny is yeah yeah he's made a fortune
outside of the show business
fantastic boy money yeah yeah he talked
about that I'm there they're like you
know how great with tech you just listen
you know they bring me and I'd listen
but I'm not I'm not like those guys he's
I just made smart decisions as far as
investment I'm not like those guys he's
a great guy man sounds like a great guy
I've heard smart kid remarry guy [ __ ]
smart very smart is he still with Demi
Moore I'm forgive me I know he's with
Mila Kunis now oh geez I can see how
vedantam hey don't send mediums about
how Brennan is condescending to me okay
don't worry about it they don't
we're we're very close and well no they
don't they don't realize that you're
condescending to you but I never respond
to them like you gotta put job in check
he's talking at me I'm like guys guys
this is what we do like I will I will
purposely float out something like
especially I mean I'll say Ashton
Kutcher could beat Conor McGregor I'll
say it's TP me it's just gonna knock out
I just throw those out there cuz you're
nuts
and then what I like to do is create a
dynamic where I'll say some [ __ ] you
tricking me now I still I stand by the
fact that Kutcher would tie her shirt
has no answer to I mean I'm sorry
Connors no any minute nope listen
straight legs
you missed the port I'm saying the port
point is this report the point is is
that don't worry about don't worry about
that you have to understand that this
hard time but also you've already lost
cuz your DM and Brian say that I'm being
mean to well they're all it's all comes
from a good place so they'd like you to
like me that just like dude you're older
but it's part of our thing don't worry
I hate when I'm not here and then so
many people did like we did this like oh
the show was terrible I'm like hey man
wait a mike hey man that's my partner
okay but dude definite never leave again
I do that all the time
Oh Mike hey hey hey that's my part
alright I feel like you're being shitty
right now I feel like you're being kind
of shitty just a knob I'm defending am I
not listen
wait you're not defending me you go look
at the numbers when you're gone it's
[ __ ] durable see my friend oh you're
being [ __ ] do me a favor because I was
busy alright but you're being shitty by
saying that never leave a good huh don't
and don't like this shouting it like
that and like as they're driving by in a
car no I pay a thousand units a Brenden
equals ratings
no that's saying that that's not fair
it's so shitty when a successful podcast
before I came come on do this [ __ ] rock
its [ __ ] rock my baby relax its [ __ ]
[ __ ] money you know what I there's
there's sometimes I'll say things
without thinking them through right so
like what I know I know somebody who is
a d1 cheerleader who did all the
friendship L know
no but it means well be yes so so that I
say to my friend Jerry who had a cup of
coffee with the Jets like you do with it
you know and also like you were he'll
you got to be careful because he's you
know it's just not gonna hear it and I
said he was a d1 cheerleader and he goes
oh because D two cheerleaders saw G one
now did he shout louder
those guys have voices and I got I was
like yeah different thing isn't it
it's a different thing yeah yeah yeah
different programs you're some kind of
that sweater card events let's go with a
current event maybe one green dude
one green choose green green green one
thing a health experts dietitian
athletes and top performers agree on is
that a perfect diet is it real dude even
with a bounce healthy diet whatever
you're on keto that arugula salad leo
know it can be tough to cover your
nutritional pain yeah dude food alone so
I let it green said hold your diet Pete
this athletic greens ultimate daily
all-in-one health drink with 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
makes it easier so you get the nutrition
that you need and here's the kicker
it's just a little little pop water
that's hang on it Bosh really good
douche sitting food but it's got a
little prebiotics probiotics digestive
enzymes an adaptogen yeah man delivers
in powder form mixed with water athletic
greens requires less capsules has a
super absorption and doesn't include any
binders or fillers nope it's just what
you need to feel good your body's a
machine you like taking twelve to
fourteen pills nope just one scoop y'all
yeah start your day the right you
apparently you get with 70 you get I
guess twelve servings of fruits and
vegetables essentially in one dude have
you tried eating 12 servings it's
impossible yep yeah but you can do
impossible just do it with this because
taking steps towards a healthier
lifestyle or your nasty-ass pushing for
better performance athletic greens gives
you the nutrients you need and why not
just try it jump on over to athletic
greens dot-com slash fighter
and claim the special offer today a free
tub with 20 servings of all-natural New
Zealand source hon percent grass-fed
whey protein with your first purchase
that's your micronutrients and your
macros micros and macro screens and go
to athletic greens calm slash fighter
for your special offer you want straight
teeth like me you got oh nope alright
nope nope nope
this is more of a substrate teeth listen
you I don't be like Brian in me I may be
straightening my teeth because I want
with another company I may go did it
worse
and and if you want straight teeth you
don't realize how important straight
teeth are if you don't have to either
you have teeth like Brennan it's
unsightly and it's hard to look him in
this face so I have to stare at his hair
look we talked about look at his mouth
I'll throw up
you can we tell you I'll cook your teeth
artists why is this why is I didn't go
with candy exactly can it now now listen
clearly age can make your tea straighter
but they can't make them wider so you
got to work on that branch look like
[ __ ] well so here's a film your day use
everybody it's finally happening 65%
less than braces on like break 65%
handed clear liners are comfortable
removable Brian talked with a list when
he had him but it's whatever you have to
set foot in a doctor's office or waiting
room your treatments prescribed remotely
by licensed orthodontist then they
deliver it right to your door yeah right
to your door they only work with
orthodontist never general dentists no
dude takes just about six months you
start seeing results before then but six
months and you're on these things your
teeth not like Brian's you ready take my
first step toward straighter teeth for a
limited time you can get started with
$75 off by using coach fighter at candid
co-ceo dot-com slash fighter that's
candid CA NTID
koat.com slash fighter use the code
fighter seventy five dollars off get
straight teeth it will make a difference
I promise
you know the you know hardest for me to
eat man you know I did when I was in
Vancouver I was shuckin and jivin I'm
like I don't eat this bad food here best
food let me reach in my bag what's this
what's this oh this is a Keats bar yeah
my Kido cookie dough some
times these bars are seriously delicious
they're made with whole ingredients like
all mints key parts have absolutely zero
sugar y'all swing with you no
replacement which is a Yost's and
they're plant-based they're totally
plant-based they're delicious man the
chocolate chip cookie dough yeah that's
I just loaded up on my back loaded up
yeah that loaded up is dust and you guys
are like man I would love to try them
okay
Oh kind rebars and free shipping getting
three bones go to key eats that's ke why
eats calm slash fighter to try key bars
for free that's right three bars for
your mouth with free shipping
she eats comps last fighter okay so this
was sent in from our boy Bryan Johnson
it was hosting the Latin Music Awards
over this past weekend and for some
reason during his performance he brought
on John Travolta and they were just
dancing together the entire John singing
John for part of it yeah I gotta see
this this was like the Latin Awards so
yeah you're the greatest man of all time
I want a beep it was a large part of me
I would like to be tiny man tiny tiny me
no I mean he's like smaller than a life
too lately no come on come on
I think it might be like five five five
he's really I've seen in person dude
like fight that guy man no oh well too
bad I lose I win a lot of people were
very confused on why John Travolta was
there it's because they look this exact
same vault this oh boy dance that
Scientology got him Bakey he's all I
know he used to be love dance what is
young man that must be a great show with
pitbull I mean maybe or or it feels like
you're in a [ __ ] rave in a blender he
just seems the same song over and over
you have so much energy for that yeah
yeah why John Toronto's there now that
that's a that's a pitbull concert
I'm watching her system daya Phil he's
just watch I think he was hosting the
Latin Music Awards and then he had a
performance during the show as well well
he's fantastic and John dropped in
Johnny what
although Travolta's in his music video
that's why I brought him out oh I like
him with a bald head I like is here but
hold this had a lot of plastic surgery
on the old fascia patient it looks great
yeah Fi where's HT killer man yeah
Travolta has gotta be 65 he was a stud
stud so good stud and a great actor I
mean really you know 6660 strong looks
better without there okay he's had know
when he was going he's young Lia's long
shell of course it's different
no he looks dope man oh come on brother
all right come on there you're kind of
the far right blue eyes no not there
blue eyes still back chin we were there
you go full mouth that strong jaw that
long he's got that dimple in his now if
you go back Jim uh-huh till the third
one on the far left
thank you that that's yeah that's I
think that's a here home that's not his
hair yes I real hurry a hair wherever
feel Vaughn gets his here that's where
he got his yeah I heard you talking
about the po2 tailpiece he's got a tail
piece he's been fat he's good he's
always had an ass
dude he's a apparently he was able to
dunk that's nuts not true
I'm currently was able to dunk he did he
lied to he's to dunk and I heard
somebody else said who saw him do it
never that's a problem John John you got
to not do that
it looks like he's wearing the wig from
The Witcher yeah it's makes me want to
leave Hollywood it really does sometimes
I just wanna I want to go away it's
tough man if I can you see me doing that
you shake my hand because I can't wait
to get the old [ __ ] lids done I can't
wait dude oh sure oppa though yet stuff
that I know of that yeah that you said
you know I [ __ ] wish I think it looks
great good yeah looks good like died the
bear yeah he looks you like
that's pretty cool on the left - she
owns a boat mcgaffey [ __ ] your hair out
of there BB both he looks fantastic
bald is tricky right yeah but he looks
great don't you think
no what ice cam I think you look sweet
bald I used to shave my head and I will
and in fact as soon as I'm done shooting
my show don't be surprised by coming
here with a shaved head well nice to it
all hey papa
that was long you're his little
differently you have to go bald kiss you
don't can't shave it that's not ready
for shave why because you'll see the
divots well will you'd have the egg the
head the bird nest maybe the bird nest
the hair transplant stuff but if you
shave this this is hanging on by a
[ __ ] thread dude so another one see
me so light here it's gonna be a little
light you have to salute like this it is
light there isn't it
what's the lightest hold on now it's the
lightest here I I will it's veal I told
you my dad was walking downstairs and he
saw me and he goes Jesus Christ I went
I'm winning this you're losing all your
hair on top there anyway it's a bad day
sometimes it's thicker than most just
light on top dude especially there what
happens if I shave it dad be a bad idea
a pride never goes back be it sue me
like you me bald out here and then the
sides are gonna be your like Oh whole
they're gonna be there you're a bit kid
dude let me shave Oh cute oh it's so
cute look at me when I used to fight
with my head no no uh-oh that right
there no to the right to the right of
that no to the left right there whoa
black belly BAM laughs now you're here
was fresh there dude precious [ __ ] dude
they're rolling with a beard yeah young
man right there buddy you're here was a
little light there little light well
this is set before I had my eye oh look
at how cute I was wonder why girls like
me
there's never
think though has it since I've known you
no but what a cutie pie I was
good-looking kid there right
you were so good-looking you're a great
man yeah it's my girl cat thanks babe
you're good-looking older man dude well
unfortunately I have lost a lot of it
that's all right hey yeah that song
that's the Spike TV guys only award when
I buddy
you know those awards aren't coming back
guys only I used to love those he said
love watching it yep then Hollywood went
not up in here really they stopped it
mm-hmm gifts nothing curt event yeah
they can't have guys only event anyway
huh okay so there was a video that was
posted online from a stray lien woman
who basically recorded her son coming
home from school crying because he was
bullied he is nine years old and he has
dwarfism I don't want to see this and
it's so so sad what he goes give me a
knife so I can stab my heart it's so bad
you feel so bad for you you really feel
this awful it's awful and she basically
posted it online just to show people
like you need to teach your kids that
this is the real repercussions of
bullying this is what happens when you
don't take it upon yourself to educate
your kids on how I'm sorry but as a kid
when I saw a child like that
I took care of them I would never do a
race right I never had friends that
would do that I mean is that true see I
mean I guess they do I guess
some kids are cruel cruel huh yeah some
kids can be cruel awful oh yeah a lot of
celebrities ended up reaching out to him
in support and he ended up actually
walking out with the Australian rugby
team and what he said that what was the
worst day of his life easily became the
best and comedian Brad Williams also
made a GoFundMe trying to raise $10,000
to send him to Disneyland with his
family it ended up getting to I think
two or four mm yeah so I saw Brad post
things and I and I was I forget what day
this was but I was gonna text Brad like
all papers flight over here and Iselin
you
I'll pay for it you don't don't worry
about raising ten grand I think I was on
my flight by the time I got off that
thing was already at a hundred seven
thousand I will definitely don't need my
help
yeah then like real celebrities got
behind it buy my off the plane [ __ ]
no Vereen was like I'll handle flight no
real money will bring you got this bro I
mean Marvel money you got this yeah yeah
and there has been some weird articles
coming out lately where people are
saying that this is a scam none of these
oh yeah they might kid be a dwarf that
was a scam people are saying that it's
not actually a kid and that is like a
grown man with all people you know even
if it is his that should be a Disney you
know I'm saying he's that guy
yeah if he's thirty what was like it was
like last night on American Idol well no
is Dateline sorry our 60 minutes 60
minutes they had this kid who was he's
blind he's born blind and when he was a
baby he was premature they said well one
the issues canvas premature his eyes
won't develop somebody came early so
they were like we have to do surgery so
they did like four or five surgeries and
before he was like even you know a month
old they did all these surgeries on his
[ __ ] eyes in a thin so the family was
like we can't handle this anymore stop
with anything ago what he might be blind
might not be able to walk talk and we
don't care we can't deal with seeing our
kid have surgeries so the kid you know
he's legally blind just complicate see
at all because blind but he can still
walk and he can talk talking's not great
but he can still do that at three years
old they hand him a piano they hand him
a piano and hear something being played
on the team or something like that and
he grabs a piano never played before
never seen a piano gets on there plays
it so his his where his brain were the
optical nerve and all that is for
whatever reason the brain goes okay
we're not use it for sight
we're use it for music so he can hear
any song hears it all he has to do here
once again right
to me he says that when he plays learn
piano sounds like six people are playing
the piano man so now and now he's
traveling the world he's one of the top
pianists and just a beast he's young
yeah he's playing he's travelling on
tour at 13 gyrate express himself
that's it so they're doing the interview
and he has he gets fidgety when he's not
on I compete a piano and they're doing
the interview and she's talking and he's
like he gets bored he gets tired he
keeps yawning and he goes carry he goes
can we do this there is is can we do
this on the on a piano she was white he
goes ma'am do you mind if I go to piano
right now I'm so tired she's like sure
and he gets on there just [ __ ] like I
see him so they studied his brain and
figure out that his the frontal lobe
that dealt with vision the brains insane
and went okay so you can't see so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna use it for
this
it's just enhanced his ability to play
music [ __ ] nuts right you know before
you play this on this note is somebody
said I came over who was it but he said
well they said why were so many of the
great jazz musicians black Louis
Armstrong and Miles Davis and John
Coltrane and Charlie Parker and the the
guy of the historian jazz story said
well because the only way a black man in
the 40s and 30s and 50s because really
expressing himself was through his horn
he couldn't talk about how shitty things
were because you know you didn't have a
voice but you could be very honest
through your music it's kind of an
interesting thing I was like BAM you
know so anywhere you have to you can
express so let me see this guy play so
that's the first guy and I just play
along with him that's why the best thing
does this probably the worst thing to
see but there's one Talent oh just your
language no it's not
you know I played piano for a year like
an earnest I really practiced yeah and
you get to a point where you can play
chords and and some notes so you can
look to somebody isn't it you look like
you can play a little bit but you see
that oh my god
yeah I really tried actually I would
have kept doing it forever I didn't I
ran out of time but I would I could have
obsessed over it it's really fun drums
and piano I try I took for you I don't
know I might get into a band I want to
start a band do and I want you on 30
dancers to be a dancer oh damn I didn't
know he was on Ellen he was in LA last
night Mike Joanna's my girl's friend
post picture on it what's the [ __ ]
chance I just found about two getting
tonight he's in LA I mean I would have
went but yeah he's a jazz musician damn
[Music]
you can hear any hip-hop song and do it
on there with the rap we could make the
keyboard sound like it's rapping
phenomenal [ __ ] nuts
I gotta take they're gonna start taking
my piano and to do what if I told you I
could [ __ ] sake right and there's
stupid eyes and go blind we can play
like that you could punch me into genius
no no I'm not saying that I'm saying I'm
gonna lose your eyes you lose both eyes
yeah at 53 years old yeah but the whole
piano but you're you're you're Stevie
Wonder on the keyboard yeah you do it no
but we're all sitting around watching
this and once almost I want man would
you I know would you guys rather like
name the worst job you ever had growing
up McDonald's Wendy's what are the [ __ ]
it is post mates what uber whatever the
worst job you ever had
would you rather do that or lose your
eyesight be able to play the piano like
this would you give up what it was even
it was even like I don't you know like
what yeah [ __ ] were you would you
Donald would you one I for a billion
dollars now hold on a billion yes hey
can I see still can I still see super
hot chicks
yep then see cool cars yep can I Drive
with one eye okay you're good with an
eye patch - [ __ ] yeah let's see one I'll
do that that eye patch of beef so you
have gold
that's with diamonds I'm like what what
wait can I see can I see my dick inside
yeah I'd do it I don't know if I would
tough for me really you don't even know
after a while dude my eyes already small
definitely do it your eye just takes
over after a while no this one because
the Bain dog that's the main dog but I
mean over here slow up bill is a bill
dog hell yeah how about one hand yep
really I'm trying to go I do with two
arms what do I really do I can still
drive I Drive like this I can't do
anything with one he didn't do what you
just take me take right here to you
he'll elbow do you know you [ __ ] it up
with my address the time for taking away
the elbow I can't wear certain things
yeah draw hair just here are you a nub
yeah do I get a cool robotic hand up for
a bit uh bill yeah take my foot take the
right come on don't say it I'll take the
left
do you guys do it Oh for a billion yes
one Haley yeah why don't you would look
as like Robocop yes oh my god
one arm my tattoo and then I have that
robot hand how would you use I guess to
feel into it I still got one another one
it's right but how would I talk like
dude you wouldn't just want with all the
the like what they're doing with no
robotics me a couple fingers would you
lose your nose for Bill what [ __ ] no I
had a teacher mrs. Roche less or no mrs.
Roche less or no that's fine
I saw a homeless guy I had to stop I was
outside of their side that Cuban place
this poor guy had had his entire eye and
his whole face I could see in his face
wow I stopped my way holy [ __ ] dude
there you are what and did you take a
wallet cash and stuff with it dude
things are looking up yeah he was I was
like you need used you have no quality
of life this is terrible so I so he gave
them an ice tea
you killed him pray for Beth Doug it's
just like I was
this pleases hell rights homeless with
no no it's not right you gotta get him
off the street he needs help
he needs help did I tell you Adam
Carolla's yeah I'm calling thing about
what do you do about the homeless people
I mean Adam goes well unfortunately with
her with you know Hollywood in
California LA especially is as long as
their people if they were homeless dogs
we'd all be out in the street yeah
people nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah I mean
it's tough man I just don't see you know
I I wouldn't lose a foot though you take
my hand at my foot dude right I was
right I would trade with a flower no you
know prosthetic on it yeah that's fine
dusting the thing smells like cabbage
you say my ear you take my ear my right
hand
Oh any fingers for a bill can't touch my
dick no feet how much your nipples now I
don't need those let me just turn on my
nipples do you nipple plants you don't
need you teeth [ __ ] no a billion did
they give the yank all your teeth no a
person is it is I don't want veneers I
want my teeth uh
B what about this what if they said hey
if you give us your pinky
we should got caught your pinky yeah we
just take a knife catch your pinky
knuckle use those style right who's the
stuff ya know they cut down on that I'll
give you four and they know not billion
don't be [ __ ] and no one's gonna pay
to do that okay but you get your hair
back full set like me you're off take my
hair put on yours well of course but of
course dunno you get no anesthesia
nothing oh no oh chop it the [ __ ] off or
that hair yeah piece of [ __ ]
it's not happening so what else you got
thanks for teaser okay so both Zayn
Malik from one direction or he used to
be in one direction and the dime piece
she's so nine piece and is cute
that's his girlfriend Gigi Hadid oh
really mmm you used to be the weekends
girl right no that's her sister Bella I
need
they say the weekend party so hard he'd
like he's out of control like so many
drugs people stop taking it with him
yeah even the girls aren't duper we're
out dude heard he's a great time but
real drug alcohol problem
Zayn Malik yeah he was at the he was in
Vegas we believe it's for the fight and
Jake Paul was actually there - Jake
released a tweet saying that he had he
was gonna slap up Zane because he was
rude to him when you try to say hi and
essentially he said that he feels bad
for child stars and saying that Zane I
know you're reading this you're just mad
that you went back to your hotel room
alone and gigi hadid ended up responding
saying lol cuz he doesn't care to hang
out with you and you're embarrassing
crew of YouTube groupies home alone with
his best friend's like a respectful King
because he has me sweetie unbothered by
your irrelevant ugly ass go to bed him
what's what Jake Paul bright wanted yeah
he's like legit like a listers to
engagement I was just never engaged yeah
why would you engage with that well yeah
a lot of people are talking about this
cuz they didn't think that you would say
anything that's the thing that's where
yeah their dads what some famous
designer right you know what I would
text back you know if you're Jake Paul
or Gigi if I'm if I'm if I'm if I'm Zane
Malik I just say if I had to take
something back I'd go like this I text
back
we the blond guy there we the bomber you
the blonde dude or the chick just but I
yeah sorry man didn't recognize you
who's this my bad dude
yeah where would I know you from
question mark yeah or let me know if you
need tickets the next I'm so sorry yeah
let me know if you need tickets that
show sorry man thanks being a fan
I'm so sorry same address you want I'll
send you merge my bad dude and I post
picture my hottest girl you good yeah no
post picture like just you good Wow I'll
steal it what else yet
so a 21 year old college pole-vaulter
had an incident where he was he ran and
he cleared it but then the pole fell the
opposite direction it was supposed to
and impaled his testicles it was
recorded he posted it on to tick-tock
and it went viral flush luckily he only
has a scar from the whole incident
everything is fine but he had to get 18
stitches show up he was nuts no but
there's a photo of his shorts after
kicking [ __ ] pole-vault by the way I
love this video no no no no could it
goes yeah you told was he wears the Hat
yes
Utah Brigham Young University BYU I
would show up each other right Taurus is
[ __ ] second half I can't yeah Heidi
ditches yeah only has a scar luckily
dude I was watching making afraid this
may be think of nuts and they I've never
seen this before they [ __ ] caught a
they had a bone arrow and they caught
like a gazelle slim pant trying to drink
water they haven't eaten in like
eighteen days one of the dirt wins when
the brothers boom snaps one and they go
the roster daily go what's tradition
when he kill your first deer or where
the [ __ ] it was gazelle you eat their
nuts
so they're both starving take that they
say cut the nuts out they get them out
they're white they [ __ ] eat then
they're strong and they're like oh it's
so smooth and creamy hey dude it's like
sushi
I make me feel sick yeah me too
and then there's these Australian girls
who are with them and they also caught a
deer and they go oh does it its
traditional we kill your first deer on
the hunt you gotta eat their testicles
and they're from like the same hair then
I never heard that
you need the nothing cap no no the twins
gay that's what's happening Kelly things
wrong with it but eat them nice boy Wow
Dan that that's is nice
yep those are you sure they kill that
gazelle with a bow and arrow they made a
bow and arrow
Wow it's impressive who's impressive I
guess now we're so excited that one
started crying almost Wow
damn I wish we had a picture of nuts
Audrey like to see those for scientific
purposes
you've horrifying horrified oh you mean
hit like our buds
yeah that's not fun well you mess up the
shaft the tubing of the shaft
dude that is absolutely terrible I love
they post that video with the future son
what else you got was that two dads
future yeah uh remember that guy that
was trying to prove that the earth is
flat and made his own rockets yes you
know he passed away he did he died in
raqqa crash he did yep you guys want to
see the [ __ ] yeah absolutely all
right here we are
he died in this yeah he died trying to
prove that the earth that's what they
said that was just a marketing tactic so
people could notice him so this is
representative so what was his plan
though just to be more famous about
building that Tim there yeah and then by
now the emergency chutes should be
coming out but they're saying that he
probably passed out during the launch
and didn't hit it oh that's him but he's
in there right now yeah oh it's going
pretty fast fast and then you could tell
well you know I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry about that
mad Mike Hughes goddamn mad Mike you
could have told you that's the way it
was gonna go yeah I just think his movie
was gonna head yeah I mean damn Mad Mike
you're just going away pour out a little
rocket fuel for him you know yeah it's
not that's not even the Athenian hit
that high yeah your stings and also
don't make homemade rockets don't make
homemade rockets now so I have definite
reason that's why
a lot of rocking are you talking about
rockets Isis that's what I'm talking
about and things still go wrong but this
guy yeah go for him that's the way he
could at least she passed out though -
hmm yeah that's true
passed out there yeah he did am mad mic
malfunction oh yeah otherwise they don't
know you know homemade rocket ship it's
a hard pass for me dude yeah god bless
them no more she was Lucy died do you
want former limo driver though so yeah
build a rocket man I didn't see that
going any other one no it had to
something like that happen you're you're
shooting a rocket off a truck but you
any Drive limos so it's like it tough
it's very tough three when the rocket
was nose-diving he didn't release the
three other parachutes he had in the
rocket let's be able to creamed and
yelled start wailing he was stunned when
he crashed and didn't know what to do
yeah well kind of should expect a
billion yeah yeah that's a bummer
thank you he helped against world record
for longest limousine ramp jump 150 foot
jump but Lincoln tower damn that's
impressive
do I believe those is shaped like a
frisbee I believe it is do I know for
sure nope that's why I won't go up in
space if they see this rare we use Flat
Earth as a PR stunt period that's what
his representative says yeah okay it's a
bummer
good run with you it's even a more
bummer if he was a flat earth than this
guy sold him out by seventy right no
well you did what he died doing what he
loved well you know god bless Wow
shut up the mad Mike dude shoutout to
Madeline oh not that old no no he's had
some close calls before though if I
remember yeah certainly has I can't I
can promise you he's had to leave least
see what I'll do what he loves man you
know you think I like a car crappy that
must be a rush is he sitting in it
what's going on with this
yeah well just imagine a thing yes you
got to space pass out for not going
space oh you know me
nobody eyes you have to Don T's you have
to forget to spay yeah but also at sixty
three thousand feet breathing out there
right well it's how I freezing because
the pressure your blood boils at room
temperature yeah but also burn but even
if your does put your femur out in 50
below zero 0:04 not made for out of
space without NASA equipment you
understand these yeah they have a lot of
issues thank yes no flights cos perfect
you somebody have a problem with the
issues you see we have a problem but
also those are the smartest people we
have to offer
that's why shoot into outer space right
and even they're like well [ __ ] dude
trying to figure it out now Magic Mike
Magic all sad Magic Mike I'm a limo
driver
it's okay drive built the rocket a
rocket tried doing the same now [ __ ] off
a truck and we're gonna go from there
and my chute didn't open
well you know why because when you do
that [ __ ] happen here's the other thing
friends and family
where were you on this one well somebody
like dude don't maybe don't try to get
to space might have been a quirky guy
who didn't have a lot of friends and
family we dare you you don't know mad
Mike that's a rocket so tiny look he's a
ballsy guy I'll tell you that much
ballsy mother [ __ ] dude lived the died
doing what he loves me so people get off
on that so only time I feel right don't
say get off but you just saying cuz he
didn't get off you know it's the juice
brother it's the juice bank-robbers
rocket launchers gamblers and all the
juice chasin juice bro that's why when
you got gangsters and try to get him to
go legit they're like I'm [ __ ] bored
too bored I'm a gangster what do you
want from me Mike I'm a comic fighter
dancer what do you want and the [ __ ]
so what do you want from me do let's
build a rock right there let's build a
rock right and add my [ __ ] let's see if
there's I'll take you to outer space
with my [ __ ]
and rocket what else you got check this
out
you check this just play this what the
[ __ ] is going on is [ __ ] the other
one no once once slurping the others
[ __ ] brain Brian and then this other
bird is whatever
what the [ __ ] kid so it looks like he's
actually trying to dig into that other
flamingoes head and I've seen what had
happened with birds before the fly hey
Bert uh-huh mug but it's not there
actually there co-parenting the bird and
is they secrete this fluid from their
own body
it's called crop milk and they're both
trying to feed the same bird at the same
time so this one's just point on I guess
you know the wife or mother one yeah
it's it's from their own body it's like
a vial because milk oh oh oh so he's
actually throwing up on the wife's head
head and it's running down yeah and
she's also feeling the same stuff I've
noticed secretion from the lining of the
crop a thin-walled
expanded portion a limitary tract used
for storage of food prior to digestion
in many birds and vertebrae's just found
among all pigeons and gum or its milk
also yeah cuz birds read well that's red
blood Wow I thought that bird was
digging into the brain because have you
ever seen like the the Falcons some get
ahold of pigeon
oh no they right in the freedom and just
no zombies dude zombie boobs
well I found my son's like daddy and
there was a dove with no head and it's
cavity opened up and it was an owl or a
hawk I'll take you owls don't [ __ ]
around ain't no house are sweet and owls
if you're a cat don't go outside at
night please or do don't like Kathy
either yeah you're getting what else you
can snatch stuff another animal one from
nature's metal
check out this moose just flowing
through the snow next these people how
crazy is that
holy Oh
d says snow is too okay move it dude
Chevy holy [ __ ] man why can't you I'd
raise a moose from a young age and just
ride Oh that'd be so cool wouldn't it
but then it'd be a horse but but an
uglier horse Oh basically ah that moose
is a move I gotta run from wolves oh I
mean the other ones aren't that great
but Harvey Weinstein got up what charged
with two or guilty of two of the parties
two of the rapes yeah yeah figure his
blood pressure isn't good one found
guilty of rape Oh
so what's chance at what chances he dies
in the next two weeks I bet I bet you
they're gonna say it's suicide by bit
somebody kills them he just starts
squealing on the rest of Hollywood not
before they get to him but he was
acquitted of the most serious sex crimes
in jail so he'll how long how much time
will we do they said though so this is
it five potentially five twenty five so
they park at five if that pays well he's
the ugliest that's attractive you'd be
fun to have him prep preying on you
Jesus right no thanks to Batman I will
suck that boy dry there's one that he
did though with the rape that he said he
got guilty huh the girl was kind of like
she's kind of weird she kept seeing him
over and over again too they had like a
relationship just a command I think
that's what yeah and then did he help
her career yeah definitely helped her
career so that's what wait so she kept
[ __ ] this girl she's super gorgeous
too ah beautiful good oh Jesus Christ
so she had been [ __ ] there like ah
and Mavis said like it afterwards I was
so fun hanging out with you tonight or
something in text messages or emails so
it's very weird but he's gonna prison
for that there was guilty that girl's a
total dimepiece and she was having an
affair with him while he
married well
his genitalia appeared deformed yeah
probably looked like his face how a man
so hold on testified that she met wine
sitting on a party in the Hollywood
Hills 213 it's his private area looked
as though the disgraced movin movin had
suffered intense burns and he does not
have testicle Oh so how's he busting
extreme scorn I didn't know if maybe it
was a burn victim he does not have
testicles and appears like he has a
vagina explain her encounters testified
that when she saw him naked for the
first time she performed consensual oral
sex get from there bad you want it girl
how bad you want it no add that she was
filled with compassion absolute
compassion she said understand that
seemed white seems anger came from a
place of shame because there were sexual
details to describe occasioned which had
in March adultery hotel for sure no say
at doubletree hotel you got money we
alleged raped her next part said she was
to meet with the former studio I had to
breakfast along with her agent who
Manson was stay in the hotel well I seen
allegedly called for a man to come
downstairs she came okay he booked room
then I really freaked out even though
they hooked up before yeah we don't need
a room he got very mad at me for trying
to speak up I was saying to the people
at the counter we don't need a room so
he pulled me aside the corner told me
not to embarrass him
she attempt Weiss to open the door and
leave when he locked me he kind of shut
down a bit she's refused to come that
mean grabs my hand to try and force me
start undressing myself
I panicked gave up trying to fend off
Weinstein undress he stood over it I was
completely naked
Tony lay on the bed I went to the
bathroom he came out naked got taught me
that's when he put himself inside me his
penis inside of me he stabbed himself
with a needle and there was blood he was
inside of me Oh God I believe everything
she's saying there was a few months
where he made grunting sound and would
look at me on it know if he was autistic
like like trait because it was a little
confusing what's the worst experience
alright she said she haunts grow up a
little bit she
said later she had dinner of Weinstein
if I chose hotel after eating she fought
him up to the suite and her testimony
man said once he started to undress
himself before offering to let me give
you a massage
only to ruin my shirt yes relax huh and
I was like it's okay I don't want a
massage
[ __ ] then ultimately coerced into giving
him so she taking massage it's the same
story he had a lot of blackheads and
tetra was uncomfortable oh now have
another meeting that's something she had
meeting over at a hotel which claimed
they would be perfect for vampire flick
he was producing yeah I said listen
girls why don't you take your time fish
drinks let's go upstairs I've scripts
I'll give you scripts so they go up
there yeah I said no no no I know what
that means then he laughed at me said
I'm a harmless old man that I get in
biscuits she made fun of me so they went
up there as he was closing door he had
me by both arms and he came at me and
was pushed me back trying to kiss my
kids I was like whoa whoa I told you now
it's not sexual
God he's terrible look he did this the
more I fought the anger he got in the
saying you're serious so I calmed him
down with a joke and he calmed down a
bit he said I'm not letting you leave
until I do something for you you totally
sit on the bed that's when he went down
and he put his mouth on my vagina uh she
started faking or even get out of it
yeah I seen when he asked if she liked
it I was nervous I told it's the best
I've ever had
ah man described once he's just dirty
told the court they smelled like [ __ ]
before correct herself excuse me sorry
poop you would say do you like my big
fat Jewish dick man said and that he
always wanted to fill me why see what
speed on her and course turned to have a
threesome with him okay yeah but you see
so so chin it seems like she's she keeps
coming back and all understand you
understand a couple things the way he
would set it up he did this to my friend
he'd be like number one if you embarrass
me you're not gonna work again I'll make
a phone call and they know that so she
wants to be an actress then he gets her
in a room like that but the way he would
do it what he did with my friend he goes
I want you to meet my wife you gotta
come up I got my kids up there and she
got their wife and kids weren't there
we're gonna go up there cuz I can't do a
meeting down here I'm just go to the
room and if you accuse him there you're
gonna make them embarrassed right so
he's like what are you doing
guys want privacy so we can actually
work maybe go over the scene then you're
there any attacks you now you go I'm
gonna be raped by this the most powerful
man in Hollywood not only am I gonna if
I say anything I'm gonna I'll never work
again it all happens so [ __ ] fast you
don't know what to do people will go
back to the scene of the trauma they go
back to it they're just like I want to
go back on my own terms or I can't live
this down and and I've been it's it's
what predators do they [ __ ] with your
head and that's what this guy did I
believe everything she's saying I
believe 100% and the reason I do is
because 15 years ago he did the exact
same I serious everybody yeah you hear a
lot of people I don't know even the
court no no what I'm saying is that
people say well she kept coming back
yeah that's confusing
it's it's different she of course she
let him go down she's like all right you
know it's all that [ __ ] man Wow I don't
know man what a [ __ ] he is so horrifying
looking - Oh a big fat Jew I've seen him
many times in person oh no cuz I had
friends who worked with him I would just
look at the guy I'd be like he's just
the most disgusting looking human being
ever seen his brother ain't much better
they were just they were just uh Glee
looking dudes man oh Sh we ended other
bird
well yes yeah is that it well I don't
think you want to see the other stuff
what is that what is it well damn it
okay any kids dying no but this is also
very sad but also cute a pizza delivery
guy who unfortunately he lost his
daughter within a week of what this when
this happened
so you'd alert a pizza and the kid just
ran up and gave him a hug wanted to get
that no idea
no you're just happy yeah
Samri has a story two year old cohen
enjoys a piece of pizza on this tuesday
how it got here will melt your heart
seven o'clock saturday what to do it was
a man by the name of Brian was their
delivery man money exchange was caught
on camera and it's priceless sweet
little boy posted about the encounter on
our Instagram page lion eventually
shared that after speaking with Ryan
Lindsay says the pair became friends on
social media you never know what people
are going through and it's just such a
good example of that that's when she
learned while he was smiling on the
outside
he'd been hurting on the inside they
went to his Facebook pages and saw that
he had recently lost his daughter Ryan
wasn't available for an interview today
but tells NBC 10 News I had been telling
my kids the whole time how much I needed
hugs before they came to see me and then
that sweet little boy gave me one it was
almost as if the universe or my daughter
Wow
was that that movie with Magnolia where
he says it's not a mistake he screams in
the bar he's got braces on he was all
full of symbolism that movie and the guy
was on shameless what's his name and he
said he screams it's not a mistake to
confuse children with angels that was
just so sweet William H Macy yeah it's
not a mistake to confuse children with
angels it's something special
crazy men so sad but it's beautiful -
yeah right and his girl she goes she
goes and my grandmother died and that
day a dove flew how the tree and flew by
us and turned and flew and we knew I was
waiting for him we knew in that moment
Oh God it was my grandma what do you say
I'm cut he goes he goes or it was a dove
and then my buddy Jerry went on my
friend's girlfriend goes I saw the deer
and it looked at me and I was in the
wild and it gave me off my buddy goes
hold on all right
it gave you love what's like when
there's funerals then it rains like
that's very raining down on us all right
whatever we live in Seattle though you
know I new shoes this hair and the dog
that's what they do
yeah my buddy later goes bet you the
Dove didn't even show up Betsy there was
no time stole that story better grandma
there's a lot of todos that it Jim
that's pretty much it that's how it goes
be I'm on the road this weekend dude
Thursday Friday Saturday Tacoma
you know what Brennan what do you need
me Friday or Saturday up with the Omaha
funnybone in Nebraska great city yep
great city great barbecue it's great
barbecue so I'll be in barbecue
I don't live great part let me build
some barbecue do it I'll be in Omaha
Nebraska I can't wait Saturday's already
sold out some tickets left for the
Friday shows I'm sorry I'm so popular
and then I'll be in Kansas City
I'll being actually Cobb Morrow Cobbs
tomorrow if you're around yeah I don't
know what those tickets are doing for
make-a-wish Foundation it's for a great
cause I'm doing it for free
and then I'll be in Kansas City Kansas
City improv April 3rd and 4th come see
me to you fat K for tickets there we are
um well Omaha's kids City right Omaha
Nebraska
oh I haven't done that one I'm thinking
kids I did the Kennedys I thought you're
saying the same when I went to yes
Tacoma Thursday Friday Saturday and then
March one night one show only in each
city theater tour Atlanta March 13th New
Orleans March 14th Toronto March 26
Detroit March 27th Minneapolis March
28th and then April 15th through
basically the rest of April I'm in
Europe Ireland Belfast Dublin Glasgow
Newcastle Birmingham Manchester London
Cardiff sweet in Amsterdam tasty fat gay
cough that it'd be great have a great
Tuesday and I'll see you Wednesday no be
moral immoral what no no don't say that
anymore and take it back this fine kid
we're out